polémique et je vais et j'ai bossé
n'explique l'an ce tournage de son
biopic sur bernard tapie malgré son
désaccord a largement déçu est choqué
c'est une série de six épisodes de 45
minutes chacun
tapie avait dit le faire ça me demander
mon accord de principe c'est pas bien il
ya des choses qu'on ne fait pas qu'il y
ait des documentaires c'est autre chose
mais emprunter mon nom c'est un peu
lourd dire des choses que je n'ai pas
validé j'ai tenu à ce qu'on regarde une
indépendance absolue ça c'est ce que dit
pardon le réalisateur son application
serait incompatible avec la part de la
fiction alors marqué ce que j'ai fait
cette semaine j'ai appelé sophie tapie
et julie sophie s'il te plait bien en
plateau et elle m'a dit mathieu c'est
pas que je veux pas j't'adore tu as
beaucoup de talent pour moi donc ça la
phase i mais elle a dit non mais la
maladie voilà je veux dire la vérité je
ne sais pas combien d'épisodes je ne
sais pas comment c'est fait je ne
connais pas le real ils nous ont pas
appelé c'est pas je n'ai rien vu donc je
vais te dire je veux dire c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien on n'y connaît rien et je
n'ai même pas vu un épisode est ce que
ça vous choque non je pense qu'elle je
pense qu'elle vous apprends rien on ne
ment pas c'est ma copine elle s'est en
effet des boîtes de nuit avec
ses tristan séguéla qui est du fils de
jacques séguéla est l'un des meilleurs
amis de d'état le tapis est alors tapis
savez que c'est lui qui allait faire ce
que la fille ne sait pas combien
d'épisodes n'a rien vu c'est là bas
qu'elle s'est tournée hier son google
j'ai tout trouvé il à ses excès bail à
voir ces épisodes y en as salé c'est si
important c'est que c'est par un biopic
c'est pas un biopic oui c'est une
fiction pire il
avait 13 ans jolie n'est parce qu'en
effet comme c'est l'ami de séguéla oui
oui oui oui à florian faut préciser
aussi que bernard tapie n'était pas
spécialement fan du ch est que ce soit
lafitte qui a été choisie pour
interpréter son personnage de queyssac
et
alors ça aussi ceci même si tu m'as dit
aussi alors moi alors un fit mais
j'adore ce type ou alors tu as rome on
partage la salle de sport
voit pas la ken mais c'est un type qui a
un talent incroyable mais c'est vrai que
ce film a dit au téléphone mon père
c'était un peu un are used as un peu
voilà ils s'en foutent bagnols lui
casser la gueule de quelqu'un voilà
c'était un bonhomme que marseille
laurent lafitte fait pas trop trop
bonhomme qui fait plus académie
française ont prévu de
se maquiller un peu non mais il est
tellement
nous par exemple est l heure était
d'accord pour fasse une série sur son
père si elle avait choisi casting c'est
ce que
je me diras temps réel tous
les acteurs la fuite et on sait que
c'est un brillant acteur et qu'il jouera
le rôle et qu'il le fera très bientôt
mais non parce que dans ces cas là tu
vous renoncez jarju nous pour jouer un
mec hyper meilleur cd
[Musique]
ils eurent ce message là il n'a jamais
joué un tombeur
l'amour est dans le pré ou un truc comme
ça oui messieurs je vous trouve très
beau week-end c'est payant d'accord bon
bref c'était par votre avis ça sort très
bientôt je sais pas quand c'est une
bonne idée en tout cas ouais ça va être
génial et bien sûr ça va s'arrêter mais
ça veut dire a cartonné à pisser même le
sol quand tu y réfléchis bien le seul
dans l'histoire contemporaine depuis 20
ans dont on aurait pu faire une série
netflix en france via leur site ou un
autre non il n'a pas élargi un débat
vous proposez c'est bon ça va vous
intéresser alors je précise sophie tapie
que j'aime plus que tout que ce n'est
pas ce que je veux dire mais en ce
moment sur netflix ya une série qui
s'appelle inventing
arnaquer tout le monde que jade ya les
arnaqueurs de thunder qui arnaquer tout
le monde tous diana un autre aussi c'est
marco mouly qu'on a reçu aussi carnac et
tout le monde et pardon sophie bernard
tapie n'a pas toujours été que honnête
puisqu'il a aussi fait de la prison est
ce que ça vous choque constamment
netflix met en avant uniquement des
arnaqueurs et pour vous dire ça et pour
vous dire in band tigana elle a fait
quatre ans de prison pardon pour ce
groupe a vu la série elle a touché 385
milles euros pour que ça soit adaptée
mais tu - demain tu prends un ouvrier et
tu lui dis tu sais quoi tu fais quatre
ans de présence hors temps tu prends
quatre cent mille euros suis sûr qu'ils
l'aient fait des quatre ans messieurs
mesdames il ya et d'ailleurs il ya new
york l'état de new york qui a attaqué
netflix qui trouvait la somme en
décembre a proposé à m
oui et on a proposé à isabelle madame
claude trouvez ça normal
non mais sans déconner
madame claude moi même madame claude
existe et qu'elle me dis pas que tu nous
proposes est ce qu'on peut faire des
sciences et de charix sur les arnaqueurs
nom est ce que ça te choque y avait des
snacks aussi est ce que ça te choque
aujourd'hui toutes les séries netflix on
met en avant que nous voyons tous mes
excuses moi ça s'appelle le cinéma
et des documentaires même les rangs
serrés ou des wimps estimé je suis pas
énormément il en son fruit et c'est
parce que cela fonctionne son regard de
faites entrer l'accusé crime et célèbre
la mode cc c'est quelque chose de
pervers chez nous on a tiré par le
succès
l'argent n'aurait de nos victimes ne se
sont dit oui mais aujourd'hui ça
pourrait être des fictions là ce ne sont
que des histoires vraies c'est pas
pareil tu vois ça a cartonné c'est une
fiction c'est ça c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire il n'y a pas que il n'ya pas
que des arnaqueurs en ce moment sur
netflix d'autant que ce n'est pas
véritablement une production netflix
attention c'est show down c'est donc la
créatrice de besoins foncé sur des
structures juridiques si on est huit
mais c'est pas il n'y a pas que ça en
revanche quand vous pensez vous parle
effectivement de sophie tapie qui est
pas totalement d'accord rares sont les
descendants de personnes dont on adapte
la vie au cinéma qui sont en général
d'atx parmi ces messieurs regardez comme
gucci par exemple la famille gauthier
pas du tout d'accord et va d'ailleurs
créé sa propre série de rencontres
céline dion le filet il faudrait pas que
jingle attention soyez chez vous
installez vous à monter alors nous ne
faudrait pas que tapie et une image de
voleurs il a fait beaucoup de choses il
a fait le plein de belles choses ouais
donc d'avoir cette image que d'escrocs
je trouve ça sera à
la fois ça sera passé à la fois il y
avait toute sa vie c'est
ça va passer sa vie à tant de sa vie je
croire 20 ans de sa vie sur cet épisode
ça va aussi ça va concerner aussi ça va
parler de ces arnaques de ses trucs de
sa vie ça va être extrapolée on sait pas
encore mais c'est vrai que bernard tapie
c'est un grand monsieur comme un
document faut tirer son chapeau
dalé comme ça le canada n'a pas qu'on
avait la productrice qui étaient là
quand elle s'appelle des arts konami
d'abord j'aimerais dire à jacky
c'est vous c'est vraiment une belle
personne d'abord vous avez une question
non c'est vraiment une bonne personne
exakis vraiment
des militaires en question une bonne
donnait là c'était mes missions que te
dis si par hasard il te regarde parce
qu'à mon avis ne regarde jamais les au
paddle mais ce que te dis que tu dises
irin ton cousin pour l'instant rien mais
je m'en rien aux il te dit je te revois
s'embrassent tu lui envoie un texto tu
dis que tu penses de moi je progresse
pour galan pas non
mais tu vous le voyez vous déjeuné
ensemble je suis sheridan là c'est le
patron de ses huit hockey
le patron de tf1 où elle est bien de
folles normale et basse mais je suis
épuisée de bus dans éloge tout à l'heure
on s'est vus dans les longs s'est
embrasée alors douanes où naquit sera
encore otis d'histoire ben on a parlé de
choses familiale familiale ouais ouais
dis moi tu es payé pour être ici j'ai
payé pour réfléchir et pdg pendant que
si tu payes et mais pour l'instant rio
où il et puis pas été payés mais pas à
lire en page et adore cette info je suis
plié mais pour l'instant ces lignes
c'est à dire mais toute façon je suis
pas je suis là pour apaiser les arrêts
de bus puis là il pour vous côtoyez
était vraiment été vraiment
j'adore connaît les réponses à toutes
les
peur cyril qui a mis qui a mis son
cousin comme il le dit pour nous côtoyer
ces
travailleurs qui voulait avoir une
petite indienne aussi dans people